welcome back y'all Dan lovey is hanging
out with us his new Netflix movie is
called good grief it's about a man who
goes to Paris with his friends after a
big life event Paris can be very
therapeutic some great movies and shows
are set there so this is a game
celebrating all of those as well as
Dan's movie it is called get ready
[Music]
America
Jesse go ahead Lord a little help us
[Applause]
left okay I'm really competitive okay me
too uh-huh me too bour from above Kelly
and
Dan I am here for you J PTO yeah God God
got sexy okay I got it that's right I
made up all the languages girl I know
what's going on okay now in this game
I'm going to give you a clue about a
movie or a show that was set or at least
partially set in Paris okay all you have
to do is hit your button and give me the
answer okay but just like half of the
artwork in the L steals are
allowed that's a Napoleon joke okay here
we go here's your first oh my God I was
thinking of the game I didn't hear give
it a minute here's your first one this
movie all built up to Fashion Week in
Paris Devil Wears Prada my goodness it
is the devil wees
Prada wo
tell you got yourself app such a great
movie I was going to the Robert Alman
film uh pra Forte which was one stomach
flew away from the perfect size I love
that movie fabulous movie yeah the Devil
May wear Prada but God always wears
Christian Dior okay here's your all
right God or Armani it's a better cut
Armani is a better cut here's your next
question it was a young rodent's dream
to be a world class Chef Dan RIT it is
to him my kids love that one that was
quick yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah fine I
see you I'm just warming up I see you
okay there you go Dan there's that
competitive Spirit you on the board now
we got a tie so here's your next clue
okay I dreamed a dream that the cast of
this musical film Dan lay Miz it is Lay
Miz you are F you are F I can't not I'm
disappointed I'm disappointed in
myself that's the one where Gladiator
and Wolverine was singing so exactly it
here's your next clue we're back to uh
Merl stre here now here in a film that
follows a
young Julian Julia unbelievable that's
unbelievable that's points right there
one yep I thought you had to ask the
question fine Dan it's on y look at her
getting all worked up here's your next
clue in this Netflix show the daughter
of Phil Collins mov from Chicago
Dan Emily and Paris it is Emily and
Paris that is a
miracle I knew that one you know what it
is you're so bad I know I'm going to
give you a clue like there is so much of
the answer already in the question I
know oh he's good oh he's all right tips
mcge all right oh he is good I I'm going
to bury you mhm okay I probably won't
here's your next clue maybe uh maybe you
could get some points on the board there
Kelly oh my gosh exactly the serious
finale to this show found Carrie Sex in
the City it is Sex in the
City it's so sad that you're losing
Kelly I'm sorry I can't don't hate me
anyway I hear your tone this thriller of
a movie found Tom Hanks traveling all
over Paris D Vinci
Code
I know that
one well that sound means it's almost
time to leave Perry we've got time for
one more question and this one is for
all the Gen sequa okay are you ready
we'll make this uh 50 points why
not this BOS lurman film had a British
poet Mulan Rouge it is M
[Applause]
Rouge and the winner
is Kelly
Clarkson Kelly has won I was like oh my
gosh I can't I could of feel bad that
that last one were so many points cuz
you definitely beat me you definitely
beat me remember to check I won remember
to check out dance new movie it's I
didn't really win it down but I lose
like that a lot on this show I I did
feel bad for a minute like really I was
really I felt bad for me I know you
killed me if there's a game night to be
had I want to be on your team remember
check out Dan's new movie It's called
good grief and it's on
[Music]
[Applause]
Netflix thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home